thank you thank you everyone good
morning welcome to this talk just before
we get started I've added a short link
to the content here I'll show you again
later when when we actually need it and
when we're going to start working on the
exercises I see a few people with a
laptop so you might have to work with
your neighbors I'll figure out something
together
so yeah the talk today maintainable
coding in data sense so we'll try to
write data science code a bit
differently than just just everything in
a notebook and list of a list of
comments there so I hope you all had
some good coffee I appreciate that it's
quite early in the morning so we'll
start with a little bit of philosophy
and try to define well what do we even
mean by maintainable code does someone
want to start with the definition nobody
so I'll give mine directly it's early so
my definition would be just just this
really really simple by maintainable
code the main thing that we that we
expect is that it will be easy to modify
what good has to be modified all the
time so maintainable code is the code
you hope can be easily modified that can
mean all sort of things and that's why
we all that's why we'll see a bit later
right so one of their many many
principles that exists in the software
development world to to help with
defining what what is maintainable code
one of them is the single responsibility
principle that just states that any any
function or class that you're writing
should really try to try to do one thing
shouldn't you shouldn't have a good
function a good class that is doing all
sort of multiple things and everything
at once instead it should really it
should really be focusing on one thing
and do it really well and that allows to
do all sort of all sort of nice things
with it later on so that's really what
we all try to keep in mind in this talk
but then in data science it's a little
bit more complicated like they a lot of
other constraints that appear there
because of the nature of what we are
trying to achieve and that's also what
what we'll discuss here so in order to
do that I'd like to first go through the
domain domain stages of data science
project so you'll have at some point to
process some data to engineer some new
features from from existing existing
data that you've got available you will
have to tune some hyper parameters of
your model to try to find the best the
best values you will have to train your
model on some data that you have already
pre processed and after you will have to
generate predictions on on new data so
let's go through all those steps and see
what what do we care about what do we
need to care about to make to make those
maintainable so for the first one
process some data where we will care
about is how easy it is to modify to
modify those pre-processing steps so
maybe you want to add some steps maybe
you want to to add scaling scaling step
to your pre-processing pipeline maybe
you want to remove some maybe you want
to modify some maybe you'll have to to
change a little bit the way you get
categorical features out of some complex
complex data so all of those you should
you should be able to do it as easily as
possible if your code is maintainable
then tune hiper parameters so your data
will change every time you will change
your features and you will you will
change your pre-processing steps you
will have to retune the whole thing so
you would hope that your your way of
tuning the hyper
meters and finding the finding the best
parameters for your algorithm is quite
easy to run and you can rerun it every
time anything anything changes to get
the best bad meters directly and then
return your model same thing for
training your model every time you will
change you will change something in the
data or even if you don't change
something yourself the data itself will
change over time so you will have to you
will need a good process to retrain
retrain it constantly and finally which
i think is the most interesting one
generating predictions on new data so
here you will have to do all the same
steps that you've done in your
pre-processing stage on the training
data you'll have to apply the exact same
transformations but ideally without
repeating any code because if you start
repeating code then it becomes much less
maintainable you have to modify things
in two different places at the same time
so how how do you do that that's that's
something we'll see we'll see later in
industry so actually right now so the
first the first thing I'd like to talk
about is how how do you make your
feature engineering data processing
stage more maintainable so again let's
let's focus a little bit on on what we
what we need to do here so for
pre-processing you will need first to
load some data you will need to split
into some training data some test data
you will probably need to drop some
features you don't need you don't need
everything there you will need to clean
some of them so remove the null values
maybe you'll need to remove some
outliers as well all sort of operations
like this you need to engineer some
features so that's probably where all
the creative part of the data scientist
job comes in where you take your old
features and you figure out well how can
I convert this this data to have
something that is it's more meaningful
form algorithm you will probably have to
apply one hot and coding on the catechol
feature
unless you use an algorithm that is that
support categorical features and that's
usually one of the big problems and you
also have to sometimes depending on the
algorithm you use scale and transform
them to numerical features that you've
got that's quite a few quite a few
things you can do you can do own your
data so let's see let's take a closer
look maybe at number six so how how how
would you apply all those steps on both
the training set and the test set so how
do you how do you make sure you don't
duplicate code here so the first idea
that would come to mind would be to
create a just create a reusable function
apply that function and test on the
training sets apply that function and
test set yeah that's good but what if
that transformation needs to remember a
state which is the case for one hot
encoding for example for scaling and
those kind of those kinds of operations
that learn something from the training
data just to make sure we own the same
page with that I've got an example with
with one hot end coding to make to make
clear what I mean by wrap so say here
you've got this training data with some
countries for for multiple multiple
people and then you apply one hot and
coding on it so that's what that's what
you get out of it so country UK for the
first row country Italy and then you
have ones and zeros there now if you
want to do the same thing on the test
data if you just apply one hot and
coding again so let's say we've got this
this data in in the test and sometimes
you'll have just one single row that you
want to to apply this transformation on
well if you've got this data in the test
and you apply one hot and coding that's
the that's the output you would get so
it would from scratch learn again the
new columns they it needs to build and
build it in the same order as it appears
in the test data so that here there's a
big mismatch that's
something that you you shouldn't do and
it's going to break your your algorithm
so here that's a good example of when
you need to to have a pre-processing
steps that need to memorize some
transformation to be applied later and
that's what that's where we would have
liked instead right we would have liked
the same columns as the previous as what
has been learned on the on the training
data and mapped to the new to the new
data set so here we see it actually that
the first one the wrong friends I wasn't
in training data we've got rows row of
zeros which is here what we want great
so in that case we we will need to build
somehow class that is able to save to
save the state and that's what the the
secular transformers will allow you to
to do and it facilitates all all that
process so there will be really our main
focus for this tutorial look at all
those tools that are provided by Cyclone
that allow you to write to write code in
a more modular way and overcome all
those issues right so some transformers
that you surely have used in the past so
the label encoder which is the famous
one the one hot encoder which we've
talked about already that I suppose
everyone has used the standard scalar as
well to to do a scaling transformation
so all of those will have the same API
the same interface they will have a fit
method that just learns a transformation
and written and saves it in its internal
States so for a standard scaler it
learns what what is the weights of the
scaling it has to do and then whenever
you call transform it doesn't change
anything in its internal state it just
applies the same transformation has
learned before on any new data right so
that's this this interface that will
reuse over and over again
some other examples of of transformers
so PCA is actually implemented as a as a
transformer with recycled loans it will
have a dot Fitz method that allows you
to learn the linear combination to go
from from your original features to the
principal components and then when you
call dot transform it doesn't learn
anything again it just applies that
transformation another one days maybe
less known is the feature union that is
quite useful to build to apply functions
on on some numerical data and get and
get there get a new array with all the
all the outputs for example here feature
Union of PCA and polynomial feature will
look like this I've got a data frame
with some value I apply a feature Union
of PCA and polynomial features and I get
a new data frame with a lot of new
columns that are generated for me some
of them will be the output of the PCA so
here I keep PCA with n components equal
to so I'll keep the two principal
components and then the polynomial
features will just generate all the
polynomial values for each of my columns
in my previous data set so here that's
interesting because I've I've used this
transformer that takes a list of other
transformers as as input and is itself a
transformer that can generate this new
data so here starting combining things
together and that's what we'll do more
and more later in this tutorial
so now I'm able to generate two first
components of PCA and put in email
component email features all at once
then you can also build your own
transformer object so to do that you
will need to inherit from two different
classes that are implemented for you in
cyclotron so you'll have the transformer
mixing in the base the base estimator so
those just contains some
some hidden methods that scikit-learn
knows to work with needs to work with
your tools and then all you have to do
is implement the fit method and the
transform method and then you can use
you can use this class everywhere you
want as as a transform object so you
could combine it with the feature Union
like we've done here or with all the
other things we will see later if you
need hyper parameters and that will
become really handy later you can just
add an init method in there pass it some
parameters and and use that as a hyper
parameter later right so here that
that's an example I've got this custom
scalar and I've built that as I said
earlier inherits from transforming
mixing and debase estimator it has here
a fifth method that is called on some
training data where it computes the
median and the interquartile range of my
training data it memorizes it with the
self the self keyword here and then
whenever I call transform it doesn't
need to learn anything anymore it can
take any any data of with the same
number of columns as my training data
and we'll just apply that transformation
here which is removing the median and
dividing by the interquartile range
right so that's super easy to actually
build your own transformations like this
they will memorize memorize of state
whatever state you need and in the
exercise that we have coming soon we'll
we'll do that together with some
transformations that a bit that are
really really common to do on Dana
actually the exercises right now so so
if you go to the so I can show again
this year old
so if you go to that URL that will bring
you to github repository where you've
got all of that including here an
exercise so if you clone if you clone
that repository you can then open what
you want to y'all
yeah sorry anyway so once you've cloned
it you can you can then open in the
exercise the exercise notebook that that
is where all the instructions are so
that's not where we're going to write
the code it's where the instructions are
[Music]
gee okay give a minute to do that you're
good with the you I'll take that for yes
so multiple things need to show here so
when you open the notebook so here
you'll have instructions the first thing
we will do here is set set this not work
magic magic method which I don't know if
everyone has used before but it's a
really useful trick if you want to
develop code in an editor on other in
another place and still load it in the
notebook so here if I run those two
those two comments
they will set the auto reload mode that
is whatever whatever function I import
from a file that I'm writing if I modify
the file itself then the notebook
automatically reloads reloads the latest
version that I've got so I don't need to
restart the notebook every time I make a
modification in my file so that allows
me to live updates the update the file
in my editor and see test it and
prototype it in the notebook so you get
the best of the two worlds so if I run
that here which provide a function that
loads the data sets
oops that doesn't work so you need to
install job Lib pip install job Lib
we'll talk about this library later it
remains here
all right here
still nuts anyway I'll just uncommon
that for now is it working for you guys
I'm just gonna come in that what
right so in the meantime was I'm solving
that I can at least explain what the
exercise is so here what I'm fighting to
load is the data set so that's yep and
here I'm just zooming on the arrow I'm
getting sir so here what I'm trying to
do it is well actually I can just load
it with spenders to show you
no but I just killed it
right so
yeah so that's that's what she'd ever
loaded with the the comment below and if
you have job Laban and scikit-learn
installed properly that should work for
all of you so that's the best data I'm
trying to load so that's the Kickstarter
data set that is quite a common one in
like machine learning competitions and
things like that
so it contains some information about
Kickstarter campaigns Kickstarter
campaign can be launched on the website
a certain time with certain certain
attributes it's here you've got
information like the description the
name of the campaign they are trying to
launch the goal so they are trying to
raise money so how much money they're
trying to raise you've got things about
from which country they're trying to
raise it in what currency and you also
have the currency exchange rate so you
can actually try to convert from a
currency to another and you've got
information about again the location the
category of the campaign and all sort of
informations like this and what we are
trying to predict is whether that
campaign will be successful or not so
we've got that information in the other
in the other file why train that's app
so here if does that comment run for
everyone else but me great so it's just
meeting perfect so that's the first
thing I wanted to explain then the
second thing is we're providing some
first skeleton for a for a muddle so
here what we've decided to do is divide
divide our model into two main files so
you'd have the Transformers here there
will be the place where you can define
all your Transformers objects so here
all the pre-processing steps that we
want to do we are saving them in this
transformers dot pi as a class with a
dot v dot transform method so all of
those you can we will implement it
together
so here you will see that we have one
which is categories x trade extractor
which is supposed to extract a category
from the JSON this one as well yeah all
of them alright so yeah so here this
class here is a transformer that will
allow you to extract some JSON that is
contained in the category information
here so we'll we'll take a closer look
later you've got this one that is a goal
adjuster that allows you to convert that
once we've implemented it will allow you
to convert a goal that is given as
dollars into I mean all the goals that
are given in anything else than dollars
into dollars using the using the the
exchange rate you also have this other
preprocessor transformer here that will
implement that we'll just load some some
dates from the from the data and compute
the difference between two days to see
how many days did the person live
between say the launch of the campaign
and whatever deadlines they're working
towards and this one is a transformative
allow you to extract the country from
from the data set and map it into a more
larger area so you can say for example
here we'll group together all the
countries in in Europe so those are the
transformers they will they will
implement and there is a model that py
which is where you'll put all the things
together and so here we've got that load
data set method that was a function that
wasn't working for me that I'll fixed in
a second then you've got a build model a
build model function that real we'll
explain a bit more later and other
functions that are that work as entry
points to tune train your model etc so
that's for the general architecture of
model here now we'll focus on the
Transformers only so if you take maybe
10 minutes should be enough to go
through the part 1 of this network that
explains how to implement all those
custom all those custom transformers
that I've that I've talked about so the
category extractor first and as you can
see here in a notebook we only have
could test your implementation and the
implementation itself is done in in the
file so if you open the file
Transformers dot by edit it's on this
side and then go to the notebook to test
your implementation it should all work
perfectly fine right so take ten five to
ten minutes to do that
in the meantime I'm fixing my error
perfect
all right have it working history and
let me know if you've got any question
so remember as well
the main structure to build your own
your own transformer something important
here is that your fit method even even
if you don't want to do anything in the
fits stage which is the case for the
first the first few transformers we're
building it needs to return itself
that's just what what circuit learn
expects so if you don't have it return
itself you have some some nasty bugs
later on
all right so let's try to do that
together now so the first one is the
category is extractor so as I explained
earlier this one is meant to to read
that field here called category father
that field here called category and
extract a certain category item it's the
first let me actually sure that field a
bit more so FedEx trained that category
you can see how it looks like so that's
some some Jason some string you know
JSON format here let me just get the
first one for example Oh cuz there is
great
so that's so here should take a look at
at that it will have this field good
slug which is the only one we we care
about here that has this information so
the first the first part of the the
field slug will be our generic category
for for the campaign and the second one
will be more precise category so here we
won't act out of this specific column we
want to extract those two this two
fields so let's implement transformer
for that so here we are already
providing two two methods the first one
the init is actually defining a hyper
parameter here that is use all there is
just a trick they added that allows to
decide whether you want to create
whether you want to extract all the
categories or if you want to extract
only categories that you've hard-coded
initially so here the idea is that there
might be so many random categories in
all those JSON fields so I've
pre-selected the main ones that I was
interested in and then I've added a
default for those that I'm not
interested interested in so if you look
at the help of the helper method that
I've
here that basically loads loads the file
loads this string here as using JSON
into a dictionary it's getting the slug
method and then it's getting the two
different the two different values as a
tuple and then here I'm just saying that
if if you're not specifying the use all
parameter you will only you will filter
so if if the first category is not in
your list of categories you care about
then you return you return a default if
your second category is not in your list
of things you actually care about you
return the default so just a way to make
sure that we don't have that many we
don't have too many dummy features later
on right so now we can implement our
tomatoes that we'll need so the fit
methods method here nothing to do we
don't need to learn any any internal
state we just extract the information
from the JSON so here I can just do
return self directly for a transform so
for the transform method i have i'll get
the data frame and i need to get the
first column category so i'll call
category equal x category so it's easier
to work with and then i need to return a
new a new data frame out of that so I'll
do return PDE data frame and this data
frame needs a column called Gen cat for
the generic category and that will be my
category to which I apply I will look
like lambda that takes an X and returns
self gets logged so it applies it
basically applies this method on my on
each of the JSON each of the JSON
strings and gets the first value
right so it's fetchers do get slug X and
I get only the first value right that
here should should work if I run that
here that if the first column works
works fine so I can create the second
column which will be the precise precise
how did I decide to call it here precise
ket and that will be the exact same
thing but returning the second value
instead and here if I run that now I get
my two columns right so that's that's
pretty pretty powerful here I've got a
nice class that is easy to maintain I
can add more functionality there if I
want later I can change the way
computing those columns fairly fairly
easily by just modifying my transform
method so it's quite easy to maintain
and as far as I'm concerned in my top
level code I'm just calling this this
extractor always the same way because it
always has the same interface so then
the goal adjuster so here that should be
fairly easy wants the same thing I don't
need to do anything with Fitz so I can
do return self here to transform I just
need to return a data frame that has
adjusted go
and the adjustable will be X so there
will be let me check so there will be
the where's it deadlines do not tell me
tell me oh is it the goal
where's the book the goals there will be
X that goal x static used the rate right
so that should do if I run that again
again what I was expecting
so I think you you get the point with
with those for the the time transformer
here that that one is actually it does a
bit more work so I'm just gonna copy
paste the others from the solution
directly so it's faster
right so for the time transformer we
load all our dates into a date/time
object here you see that we actually
multiplying the timestamp by a constant
value because they were not given in in
the right format so that allows you to
get three timestamp objects the deadline
the created date and the launch date and
then we can start creating a bit more
creative feature so that's that's some
nice feature engineering here where we
say well what we care about really is
how much time there was between when we
launched the campaign and in the
deadline that you had so here we can
easily compute it as number of days and
same thing how much time you spent
between when you created the page and
and the launch time of your campaign so
let's look at this one so that returns
two nice columns with that that
information and then the last one which
is if you if you wanted to group
together some countries in as as groups
for example so here I've created a map
where I'm saying well all those
countries should go in the following
groups and that's a fairly simple one
where we spend as I'm just calling the
dot map method to to map all of those
together so here country transformer it
returns returns if I do dot sample
should be better and here you've got all
the other groups right so that's for
custom transformers next we will look at
a bit more advanced thing so one one
really cool thing that was added in
Sackett learn 21 so the latest version
is the column transformer so how many of
you have used it before
okay so it's it's really useful and so
it allows you to to map different
transformers to different - to the
columns that you're interested in so
that allows you to say well this
specific transformation should be
applied to say all my numerical columns
this specific transformation should be
applied to all my cat Oracle columns and
that allows you to start creating rules
on what transformation should be applied
to what part of your data frame so
here's an example we've defined some
numerical columns so the age and salary
some categorical columns the country and
the gender for example and we create a
new object we say that's a column
transformer it takes a list of tuples
and in that tuple you'll have three
different elements the first one is the
name you want to give it the second one
is the actual transformation and the
third one is the list of columns to
apply it to so here I'm saying well I
want to apply PCA not on my whole data
frame but only on those numerical
columns and I want to apply one hot
encoding on only those those columns so
that's really powerful if you combine it
with what we've seen before so you can
start building transformations and
decide then put them all together in one
single object that map's them to
different parts of your of your data
frame so using all of that you're able
to build a master processor object that
those all the transformations at once
and memorizes all the states that it
needs to so that's a more visual example
here where we're doing doing the same
thing as I explained so we apply PCA on
numerical columns only that's where we
get in the new data frame and we apply
one hot and coding on the catechol
columns only and then the column
transformer will just work as a normal
transformer so once you've created that
object you can call dot fit on some
training data it will learn the the
internal state for all the
transformations that you've you've
provided inside it then dot transform
will apply that on any new data so of
course you can do it on your
training data but you can do it on some
test data that you want to process or
later on
you can do it on some new data that you
need to generate predictions for on the
fly so it's a really nice really nice
tool another one pipeline there is older
allows you here not to do things in
parallel like the column transform will
do but sequential operations so for
example you might want to scale some
data first and then apply some pca
transformation on it so pipeline you'll
just call the pipeline object again pass
a list of tuples where you define what
what is it that you want to do so here i
want to create a an object called scalar
that scales my data and then pca so here
all those transformations will be done
one by one on all all the other columns
that you've got available in your in
your data so that fit on the data then
the transform that's how it will look
like so if you combine those two you can
already anticipate that you can start
building pretty pretty complex pipelines
by having this pipeline that those
sequential operations and then the
current transformers allows you to map
it to specific to specific columns only
yeah so it can be used together with the
column transformer so here that's an
example of that here we're going to
steps so we're first creating a pipeline
object that we want to use only for our
numerical features so that pipeline
object is for scaling the data then
applying some PCA transformation on it
so that our first transformer and then
we build a top-level column transformer
object that applies this specific
transformation that we've we've created
on the numerical features only and then
for the categorical features it applies
one hot encoding right so you can start
building more complex more complex
transformers this way
so the great thing here is really this
the second point is that you you're
making everything really really modular
like every every sort of operation every
functionality of your code will be a
separate class a specific transformer
that does something something specific
really well you can test it later and
then you you're just building pipelines
by combining them together so that's
allows you to keep your code quite quite
clean here the only thing we are missing
so far is the predictive predictive
model part of of our code well actually
that's not completely true because
pipeline can be used for for
transformers but it can also be used
combined with a predictive model so if
you use a as a last step of your
pipeline not a transformer but an actual
model that has a dot predict method the
pipeline will automatically inherit that
that predict method and be able to
generate predictions on your on your
data directly so that means that you can
you can do something like that so you'll
have your processor that we've mentioned
before which here is a column
transformer object that does something
on the numerical columns and do
something on the catechol columns and
then we put that inside another pipeline
that has a preprocessor stage so that's
your that's your your first your first
level here and then the second level
which is whatever algorithm you want so
here we've chosen a decision tree the
great thing about that is that your
model isn't isn't just an algorithm
anymore and all your all your hyper
parameters are not just on your model
anymore so it's not just about choosing
the best parameters for your decision
tree it's about choosing the best
parameters for all your pre-processing
steps together with with your final
algorithm the decision tree here
so maybe changing the values that you
have in your the components that you
keep in your PCA will affect the best
parameters to choose in your decision
tree so it's normal to have all of those
tuned together and train together and so
here that allows you to do that to
represent a model as not just an
algorithm but a bunch of pre-processing
steps plus an algorithm at the end and
that also that's also really good to
avoid data leakage because you you have
all the steps run on any batch of data
you provide so if you're doing
cross-validation all the pre-processing
steps everything will be done only on
that single batch that you provide him
instead of leaking some information
potentially from other batches if you
did the pre-processing before the
cross-validation and you can easily
apply that pipeline to any new data once
you've managed to train it it's just a
matter of calling dot products and it
will go through all the pre-processing
steps plus the predictive the predictive
part and finally yeah it's more modular
so it will be much easier to test and
maintain so we've got an exercise for
this as well which should be fairly
short so maybe let's take five minutes
for you to take a look so here it will
be in the model dot buy file where we've
defined functions that that puts all our
transformer objects together so here the
first one the most important one is the
function that builds the model so it
basically so here two first steps that
we're providing it creates a pipeline
for our categories that we've extracted
with that categories extract object so
where it does is that it first calls
transformer and then it calls the one
hot and cutter to create dummies out of
that and we also have another pipeline
that is for the country the Contra
transformer so same
thing is just creating dummies out of
the the catechol features so those are
just the steps that are provided then
the exercise here is to create a column
transformer object that has all the
steps all the steps we want so it will
have this one the it will have the
category processor it will have the
country processor it needs to have as
well the other the time transformer and
the goal adjuster yeah so yeah if you
take a look for the next five minutes
and then go threats
all right so that's let's do that that
part together now so the first the first
step here is to create your your main
column transformer object will they will
basically put everything together at
this stage so we'll just create a new
column transformer how I even imported
it yep so I'll do preprocessor column
transformer so here I need a list of
tuples so the first one will be for my
categories so here I will just apply the
cats processor and I've got a list of my
categorical also here this one is just
the column category right so here my
categories are actually extracted from
from only the category category column
so if I provide this processor this
transformer object only the category
column that should be enough then I will
need countries there will be my country
processor and I just need the column
country there then I will need to use
this what else I got the goal adjuster
that needs the goal column and the
static USD rate column so I'll call that
how do they call it the solution I call
it goal
so there will be the goal address Terps
go register
and that will need the gold column and
static USD rates and finally I want as
well the time transformer so here I'll
call that like all the time yeah called
time fly the time transformer and I will
need those two columns the stay columns
the deadlines created that and launched
at deadlines creating that I'm just
right so oops still missing one thing so
that's for a free processor object so
now I've got my pre-processing stage now
I need to put it together with some
predictive model so I'll just call it
called model there will be a pipeline
where I basically have two stages so pre
processor will be my pre processor I'd
define just above that's my first stage
and then my second stage will just be
some algorithm sir let's call it model
and here think I've already imported the
decision tree somewhere yeah so let's
just do decision tree decision tree
classifier with just default default
parameters for now cuz we're going to
tune it anyway
so did I do something wrong
is it going to work doesn't work
I need to return it that would be good
all right
category the category there is category
you list
check
oh yeah any cheaper service okay that's
my foot
need to pass everything is a list here
okay right
and now that's working so that's that's
pretty cool here because we we've got
all all our model now can be built with
this single function and we can return a
new instance of our model including all
the steps that it needs with one single
one single function so here that's quite
easy to change to change the pipelines
if I want to the last step creates a
preprocessor preprocessor with older all
the things all the features that I need
to build and the really last one puts it
together with some algorithm so here
from from top-level point of view I just
need to instantiate on your model
calling that function I can fit it on
some on some data and then I call
predict and it works just like any any
algorithm even though it has all the
people sing steps included to it right
so next let's go back to slides right so
now we've got about everything and with
everything we need to to build the model
and we're ready to start thinking about
training it and tuning it and all of
those so here the first thing that we
need to we will need to think is how
when we're training our model that's
something that can take a while and when
we're generating predictions we need
somehow to be able to load a model that
we've trained we've trained previously
so here we will want to be able to save
somehow that model on disk and be able
to out train model on disk and be able
to load it later to use it say if you
want to use it on for in production just
to generate predictions you don't want
to retrain it every time so here
that's what model persistence will mean
so they're two main ways of doing it
with with button of sterilizing objects
you have pickle that is quite quite well
known and job Lib there is a bit less
known today pretty much pretty much
equivalent in terms of performance in
their documentation job Lib says that
they tend to be more efficient with with
larger arrays so we might prefer that
for working with pandas and in umpires
with object that work we spend as and
don't buy something cool with job Lib is
that the interface is just a bit easier
to use so that's how that's how you
pickle your model using the pickle
library so you'd have to open the file
in binary then dump it and then open the
file again in binary and load it if you
want you to do that with job Lib it's
just a bit easier because they abstract
from you the loading the file in binary
mode so you can just drop lib dump here
you've got your model so that's your
single single object pipeline that has
been trained that has you you have
counted there it has everything you need
in it and then you specify your file and
it will just dump the whole object on
that file and then later on if you want
to load it it's really easy you just
call dot load and past the path that you
want to load just keep in mind it has
some limitations so people and job layer
will just pickle that specific object
that you're specifying which is why
actually it's important to to have one
single object but it does not save the
dependencies so it will not you will
still need the code that that it relies
on to to run so that means all the
libraries that it's calling but also
your custom your custom classes
everything you will need the files to be
able to run it also the data is not
saved so if like you need to retrain
your model you also need to make sure
that you have snapshots of of your data
other other thing to keep in mind when
you're using those libraries is that the
versions are really really important so
since it's relying on whatever whatever
libraries you've got installed when
you're loading the model if it has been
saved with different versions then it
can often have have some problems so
it's really important here that you
you're keeping track of what versions
you've pick your gmod always and make
sure that whatever environment you load
the pickle from will have the exact same
versions and dependencies installed in
the last class comment here is that yeah
you can pickle anything any any object
in Python so make sure that you don't
load some pickle that has been provided
by some in some places that you don't
trust because it could contain anything
excluding including some scripts that
mess up everything so keep that in mind
so we've got an exercise for that where
we are going to here implement the last
so we only need three things now for our
model to be able to run it to run it on
the command line so we need a method to
tune it we need a method to train it and
we need a method to test it so we've got
all of those all of those here so let's
let's yeah we got time so let's take
another five minutes to look at that
should be so here it should be fairly
easy you only need two for tuning for
example you will need to call your your
your function that builds a new instance
of the model that gives you a new
instance then you need to you can use
grid search directly on it so grid
search super supports the suppose the
pipeline the pipeline objects
so here what we have done is defined in
a config that by file your great
parameters so you can uncomment that or
just come up with your own parameters
that you want to tune so here for
example we're saying that we want to
change the max depth of the modal stage
of the pipeline so here the max depth of
the modal stage will be the max depth of
our decision tree we want to tune the
min sample split of that decision tree
as well so model underscore underscore
the name of the attribute in the
decision tree and then we also want to
attune some of the some of the
parameters of preprocessor object so
here are preprocessor object we can
change use all from false to true so
those are a few example if I do that
actually I can just tip so if you do
model don't get params that gives you
all the parameters that are in your
pipeline object in your model so that
tells you all the steps that you've got
the actually zoom in a bit more all the
steps that you've got there so it's
quite a big one if you do dot keys it
tells you all the parameters that you
can that you can tune that you can tune
there so that's where you see that so
you've got the things on your where is
it you've got all the parameters that
are on on your model so like class
weights so all of those are defined on
on my decision tree so I can tune all of
those but I can also tune everything
that is defined on my preprocessor so
that's the that's the one that I've
chosen to tune here right so you can
access all those parameters and provide
them in the in the grid search actually
it may be better if I just do it
straight away
all right so let's let's just do it
together so here first step for tuning
the tuning the model is well load the
data so a lot X train Y train load data
set to have the data set here no it's
the data set data set and I want to load
okay I'll just copy that part from here
extreme watching right so first I load
the training data then I'm creating
instantiating a new model so I'll do
build model and then I can call grid
search on it so have I loaded the growth
research yes I have it there so I can
define a new grid search object here
there will be GS equal grid search CV I
pass my model directly I will pass the
parameters that I've defined in config
so I'll first uncommon them they said
whoops okay
so now I go here I imports all of those
great poems and I can start using them
okay here I'll do CV equal say three and
underscore jobs equal minus one then I
do GS that fits on X train why train and
I can just print Vasco will be so here
you don't necessarily want you to print
maybe you want to actually get those
parameters and automatically retrain
your model with those parameters but
keep things simple I just do it like
this vesko let's see if that works here
so if I call that know I need to imports
as well
extreme my train right
it's nice chilling my model
and here it's telling me the best go I
can also add it to tell me the best
parameters best poems chillin again
and I tells me as well what are the best
parameters that I've got in not in my
algorithm only but in my whole in my
whole pipeline so it's telling me that
actually I should use max depth of nine
of nine in those parameters for the
decision tree but also it's answering my
question I had at the beginning of this
tutorial which was should I use all all
the categories that I get from the data
frame from the category column or should
I use only a subset of those well he is
telling me that I should use all instead
with those parameters of the tree so
that's that's quite nice that allows you
to add some extra parameters to to tune
in there so we'll do the same for
training so for training we'll need
those two first then we'll do a model
that fits X train y train so that's
quite simple here and then the the last
step is to save it onto a file so we'll
do a job Lib dump
we'll save just have one single object
to say which is our model and let's give
it a name model
job Lib so here I do not have a model
dojo blip yet so I can see if it worked
if I run that extreme train if I run
that oops
still not import job babe no good I
commented out creating traps for myself
and I strained it and you see it has
saved it here what's binary file so I
can't open it but it has saved it on
this so I'm able to load it later and
actually that's the next exercise
loading that and generating predictions
so here test model I'm just going to
load directly model the job lib
that would be my model then I need to
load some data as well so I'll use that
here but it's not extreme it's X test by
test and I need to import that as well
at the top right so once I've got that
now I can easily just compute accuracy
score classification report anything I
want I just do white bread will be equal
to model that predicts X tests and then
I can just do print accuracy will be
format Y tests white bread you can try
that here that's the wrong one here it
is right so here
my bad
accuracy let's go
all right right so now I'm also able to
easily test test my model and I can add
classification report to that if I want
nope
okay right and now I've got the
classification report as well right so
that's that's quite nice now I've got
pretty much all the code I need properly
modular and separated so I can easily
make modifications so I can modify the
existing transformers that I've got here
in this file by changing the way say I'm
computing the category or I'm computing
anything here I just need to focus on
the transform method inside my class if
I want to add an extra step I just
create a new transformer I can test it
individually making sure it works fine
and then in the model dot by I just need
to add it here in the build model as an
extra step so either I have to create a
pipeline object I add it directly to my
top level column transformer if I want
to change the algorithm I'm using it's
quite easy as well to do here and then
I'm just modifying the parameters that I
want to turn to correspond to to my to
my both algorithm and in steps and it's
all I can do all of that together here
so also providing some common line tool
out of that because it's easier to just
run it directly from the command line
instead of having to start the shell and
call the commands the functions yourself
so here we've just defined rounded by
that those basically imports are three
main entry points so that thun model
train model and test model and then just
use the arc pass library in order to to
have that as arguments on the command
line so if I test that now
did you see the exercise and yes i zoom
in here if I do pattern run up I stay
tuned then we'll turn my model as it
says and tell me what the best
parameters are maybe yeah so here you
can reach unity easily so every time you
make a new step you're changing the
steps in your in your code you actually
don't have to go through the notebook
anymore you can just run it here and see
how that improve how that improved your
your cross-validation score and how what
what are the best parameters that you
should use when you train your final
model I can also do train if I want to
train my model again and save it as a
job lib cellulite file and then whenever
I run the test I can see the final final
value of my score classification report
anything I'm interested in really and we
could implement another another entry
point that would be for predict that
could be predicting loading the
serialized the sailors model and
generate predictions on any any new data
that you provided so that would be that
would be the comment you would use if
you use that model in production so a
few a few comments things that I have
skipped a little bit so first it's quite
important so we're going to be loading
data that will they will change
sometimes you'll have large training
data sets sometimes you'll have a single
row
so here it's missus it's it can be quite
risky to to just rely on pandas
inferring what type what types your
column should be so it's really
important to whenever yoga you you want
to make it to make maintainable version
of your of your of your codes to use to
fix the D types so that's where we've
done here
we've just specified the d-types for all
the columns and whenever we actually
loading the data with that function
that's why I've provided that function
here we make sure that every time we
load the data we specify the same the
same D types and that way we're sure
that something won't break because some
some data has been loaded has been
inferred as a different type than it was
important to have a requirements that PI
as well so the text sorry since we here
we are stabilizing our model and we
expecting our model to work for to work
in the in the future and support to make
sure we can replicate exactly the same
the same environment over and over again
so requirements the text with the actual
versions of the library will help you
doing that yeah if you're making
incremental changes make sure you you're
checking the the disco in the tuning
steps of the cross-validation score and
not the not disc on the test set because
that would obviously be massive massive
massive of overfitting to do that so
just do all your feature engineering
using the the tuning cross-validation
score and yeah the really cool thing is
that this this is quite modular so you
can easily write tests so that means you
really should now it's it's it's quite
straightforward actually to just take
this all those transformers in isolation
and build build tests for it and
actually that's what that's what the
next section is about yeah and with all
of that
hopefully you're updating your test
should be your model story so it should
be less stressful just yet to finish we
we have a booth somewhere tomorrow so
just come say hi
[Applause]
five minutes for questions do you have
any yep
oh yeah you could use numpy so it it
realized on so the question was does it
work only with spenders or with numpy as
well so yeah it since like all of all of
the Transformers from from psychic land
except either numpy array or pounders
right here turns out that the actual
Transformers that I've built
I'm using some some pandas method so my
own code will not work with fairness
with oh yeah you need to specify the
column there yes so it's not it's not
this one it's not going to work with
with number because it's relying on you
specifying what column it should be but
the rest should do yeah any more
questions yeah so with the big color the
other one was called Java yep so you
mention a couple of limitations is there
any other way to store circular model
yeah so we say I want to I turn a model
and then they pass that to someone else
so here did that that's actually the
recommended way on on scikit-learn on
their documentation they're using so
they don't have a custom way of doing it
they do using pickers and job Lib which
are like just generate by then once if
you want it to store that it just just
just the data then does has a binary
formats that that they're using so you
could do that with the model itself not
really
cuckoo few time then
[Applause]